hello and welcome back to how to counter
aggressive openings in chess So today
we're going to talk about the scotch
gambits so it starts with E4 E5 Knight
to F3 Knight to C6 and here white plays
D4 now I should note this can happen in
multiple move orders so this could
happen after for example Bishop to C4
Knight to F6 and then D4 so we'll see
how this transposes
after a position like e takes
D4 so anyway after Knight to C6 D4 this
is the scotch game and then once we take
on D4 Bishop to C4 is the scotch Gambit
because they're ignoring this Pawn here
so after Bishop to C4 we want to make
sure we're very careful we don't want to
be passive and let white gain the
initiative so right away we start with
Knight to F6 we're developing a piece
and we're attacking this Pawn on
e4 so right away this looks pretty nice
but what if he just moves this Pawn
after this move black actually has
multiple options but the best one is to
play D5 and we saw this in the last
video D5 is a really key move we're
staking our claim in the center and
we're fighting back we're not letting
white gain the initiative at attack us
we're the one forcing the issue so D5 is
so so important and after D5 the bishop
goes to B5 and if they were to take on
F6 right they were attacking our Knight
and we just ignored it so they could
very well um take on
F6 and then after that we would take
their Bishop so we're trading our Knight
for their
Bishop um and if they keep taking we
could throw in this check here with
Queen to E7 and after Queen E2 trades
and we take here after the dust settles
all the trades black is much much better
see the eval all the way down here
because black is not only up a pawn but
is just dominating the position has
complete control of the center with
these pawns the Bishops are slicing
through the board we're going to Castle
bring the Rooks to the E file it's just
every single one of black pieces is set
up for success
so um eex F6 is definitely nothing to be
afraid of and then eex D6 is also
nothing scary we're just going to take
back with a bishop and after we take
back with a bishop we're ready to Castle
and white pretty much has nothing we're
already uh much better because we have
this extra pawn and white has nothing
for it so if we go back after E5 and
then D5 White's best move is to play
Bishop to B5 so in instead of taking
they just kind of keep the tension in
the position and pin our Knight they're
planning to potentially take back on D4
since this Knight is now pinned so after
Bishop to B5 I'm going to recommend this
fun move Knight to D7 now the main move
here is to play Knight to E4 this is the
main line but Knight to D7 is tricky and
it's still uh very good black scores
very well winds more than white in this
position so after Bishop to B5 I'm going
to recommend Knight to D7 because this
can throw your opponent off and it's
going to give you a really fun position
it's very Dynamic and there's a lot
going on either side can play for a
win either side can play for a win so
after Knight to D7 a lot of people will
take on C6 because they want to try to
win this D4 pawn and the Knight was
protecting it
so after Bishop takes
C6 this is actually a mistake and we're
going to see how we take advantage of
that so first we take back with a pawn
now after Knight takes D4 we're going to
actually play Knight takes E5 so this
Knight is not only snacking on a pawn
but it's defending this Pawn on
C6 and this is a very important Pawn
this is not just any pawn this is
White's most powerful Pawn in the
position their only Pawn in the center
so after we take this we have complete
domination in the center white has
nothing attacking the center so after
Knight takes E5 just to show what might
happen white could Castle we could
develop our Bishop and they might try to
take advantage of the fact that we still
haven't castled yet they give us one
more move we're going to Castle we're
going to be fine but they could be
really aggressive here and play F4
trying to kick out a knight and then
check us and we don't really have a
great way to defend if we played a move
like Bishop to E7 we would be losing
because Knight takes C6 comes and is
very very dangerous so here it's
important to note we could just play
King to f8 and King f8 looks a little
weird we're not castling but this is
very very strong because we have a very
strong attack in this position if we
ever plays H3 we can meet that with H5
and sacrifice our Knight to open up the
H file and attack
White's King this is a very very rich
position with a lot of attacking
opportunities we could open up this
diagonal for a bishop we play C5 D4
bringing our Queen Into The Fray with
Queen H4 is a nice idea as well there's
a ton of ideas in this position and it's
a really fun position to explore so if
we go back Bishop takes C6 is actually a
mistake because we generate this attack
so instead of Bishop takes C6 white
should play castles and this is the the
best Line This is what white should do
and after this we're going to play
Bishop to
E7 I should note Bishop to C5 um doesn't
make as much sense because although it
looks like you're trying to hold on to
this pawn it doesn't really work out
white is going to take on
C6 and after we take back they can
actually play this really annoying move
Bishop to
G5 um and it's a very awkward position
because we don't want to play
F6 um and we don't want to move our
Bishop again so it's just it's not ideal
so we start with Bishop to E7
controlling that G5 square and preparing
to
Castle so we let white take on
Z6 and then take on D4 and this time
it's a little bit different this is the
reason why this is better for white is
because we actually can't um or we can
but it's not as good take on E E5 in
this position because if we did take on
E5 white would attack this Knight with
Bishop to F4 we would have to move it um
say Knight to
G6 and white can actually throw in this
move Knight to C6 grabbing that pawn and
material is even our King is still in
the center so white has a very nice
position here so if we go back Knight
takes E5 is not as good here but we
still have a good position if we play
Knight to B8 so this is one move that's
really really weird we're undevelop a
piece but if we can remember it it's
going to give us a really nice position
um because after Knight to B8 White's
going to develop and we get our King out
of the center so if we kind of take
stock of everything that's happened here
we have two
Bishops because white traded their
Bishop for our Knights and white only
has one Bishop so this generally is a
very good advantage in open positions
because the Bishops are long range
pieces they can cut through the board so
in this position if we can open up the
position if we could open up this long
diagonal with C5 and D4 then we're going
to have a much better position so this
position is roughly
equal but it I really really like this
long-term advantage of having the two
Bishops and just having better central
control this Pawn on C6 can become a
very strong asset once we move it to C5
controlling the D4 square and this Pawn
on D5 again after we push it to D4 is
going to be very very strong so our
pieces can come alive and we can have
complete domination of the center once
again with these two c and d pawns so I
really like the position the two Bishops
are very very strong and this is how you
can counter the scotch Gambit